the port of blyth used to be europe's
biggest exporter of coal
then came the climate crisis blithe has
transformed itself into a hub supporting
offshore energy this ship lays cables
along the seabed
transporting electricity from the wind
turbines which have come to dominate our
landscape
[Music]
we're heading out to sea from the
northumberland coast
to one of the uk's fast growing number
of wind farms
this is where the prime minister is
pinning his hopes of delivering on a
bold boast
for the uk to beat a wind what saudi
arabia
is to oil the uk has what many countries
don't
an abundance of wind here in the north
sea these giant
turbines are generating clean renewable
energy
when we talk about reducing emissions
and tackling
climate change this is part of how
that's happening
this is what the journey to net zero
sounds like
the uk is already the biggest producer
of offshore wind energy in the world
but if you add in onshore wind its
global wind production ranking per
capita
drops to eighth and according to
business leaders
the prime minister's wind plan has been
slow to benefit
the wider economy the vast majority
of all wind turbine components are built
abroad um so whether that's
germany denmark and spain france etc
and that's from the top of the turbine
to subsea
is there a chance of the uk getting to
net zero
um to a large degree because of wind
energy
and the uk economy missing out there is
uh
you know we're in the premier league in
terms of offshore wind installed
capacity
we're currently probably non-league in
terms
of benefits to the economy this was the
world's largest wind turbine blade
arriving in blythe to be tested
it was made in france they're bending it
like a ruler
making sure it can withstand the force
of a typhoon
at 107 meters you get a sense with me
and the director of the test facility
walking underneath
just how long it is but it's nearly too
big for the hangar
this is the biggest blade test facility
in the world
but when the prime minister visited last
year he was told
ambition has to be matched with
investment
what i tried to emphasize to the to the
prime minister
was that the growth in this technology
has been so
rapid and that we're at capacity
in more ways than one and if we're going
to keep the uk
at the cutting edge of this technology
then we need to continually invest
in research infrastructure to keep us at
the leading in that leading position
growing renewable technology means jobs
for people like matthew
a former apprentice who now works in a
test center control room
born in blyth he was made in the green
revolution
i've recently just had a young daughter
and i feel as if it's something that is
really helping towards future
of her as well it's not just an industry
now that is
a job as you say it is something that is
benefiting not only us
personally but the the world as a whole
helen and her son
know the benefits wind energy brings to
the community
but have different opinions on the
aesthetics of blythe's land
turbine which you can't hear but also
can't miss they're really good
i've got no compliments about them it's
better than
cool welcome don't eat because it used
to be a
black just a black cloud of wildlife one
time
when the power station was good what do
you think of them to look at
was a bit of an eyesore whatever they
look like the government says
wind turbines will power our homes by
2030
but that won't leave much wind energy to
export
which doesn't look like making the uk to
wind what saudi arabia is to oil
anytime soon lisa holland sky news
northumberland